- What did you say to Andy
to get kicked out of camp?
♪♪
- I was home from school,
and I was watchin' you.
There was helicopters.
Like, can you take me
to that day, please?
- This was during training camp,
and this particular day
it was the receivers' day
to sign autographs.
Well, so, I had
a groin issue at the time
so I just felt like,
"Let me use this time
to go get myself healthier
in the training room."
We had a bit of a disagreement.
And it was, like,
right in the doorway
of where, you know,
people were—
- A lot of players
and coaches saw it.
- Yeah, and I think some
other people just, you know
listened to the conversation.
- Right, right.
- So, you know, he felt like
I was showin' him up.
And Coach said, "Go home."
"In the meantime," he said,
"Keep yourself in shape while you're at it."
I'm in the house
maybe 20, 25 minutes.
I start hearin' helicopters
or whatever
but I didn't think much of it.
Somebody came
and knocked at the door.
And I looked through the blinds.
News trucks
were all out in my yard.
The helicopters and everybody
was around my house.
I just tried
to have fun with it.
Saw my ab bench,
took it outside.
I was, ya know,
entertaining the reporters
and I was workin' out
at the same time.
Little did anybody know,
I had an earpiece on.
I called my publicist
at the time.
She was listening to every question
that was being asked of me.
And so she told me kind of
what to say, what not to say.
And so I just basically said,
"No comment," or whatever.
- Right.
- So, did you go back and you're like
"Andy, I was keepin' myself in shape."
- Well, yeah. I mean,
at some point
he kinda figured that out.